turn around mr. two things are gonna
happen first that phone over there is
gonna ring second you're gonna be
wearing these cuffs who the hell are you
I'm the guy you didn't count on Jack
Reacher Purple Heart Silver Star you're
a legend there is this dent and the dust
people say you made it with someone's
head I need your help
they killed my men men that used to be
under your command I know what you have
done for should've stayed out this
followed man here that was a mistake
really
fellas why do I get the feeling that
you're enjoying this
a very interesting way of saying thank
you
sorry he's not feeling you might want to
use this bell happen in his fight one
guy took them all down with his bare
hands turn around mister you see ants
slowly aggravated assault is a felony in
this state mr. Reacher processed him and
get him to County
two things are gonna happen in the next
90 seconds excuse me
first that phone over there it's gonna
ring second you're gonna be wearing
these cuffs on your way to prison well
that is one magnificent prophecy
mr. Reacher just gonna keep on ringing
when you coming to DC I move around a
lot you're a legend folks wonder why you
left Purple Heart Silver Star there is
this big dent in the dust people say you
made it with someone's head Jack Reacher
from agent Turner major Turner has been
arrested on what charge espionage
he did sent him how much does Region
know how's it going I don't like being
followed
you think you're invulnerable that's
right
maybe I rip your arm off beat you to
death with it I'm sorry
each give Herto Julia
my men were shot by one of our own this
is bigger than I imagined you ever lose
anyone on your watch Reacher
you're a dead man
you think you're above the law
but I'm not the law so you should start
running because I'm gonna start hunting
and when I find you I'm gonna kill you
all
it's a haircut oh you guys go to the
same barber